well the US has criticized South Africa
for bringing a genocide case against
Israel before the un's top Court an
initial hearing at the international
court of justice in the ha is due to be
held next
week find this submission meritless
counterproductive and completely without
any basis in fact
whatsoever well speak to Maran Bashar
senior political analyst who joins us
here on set so Mar is a DA for John
Kirby soundbit it's between you and me
isn't it we were talking about a
different one in the past hour what do
you make of what he says here that the
icj this case that South Africans are
bringing against Israel is
meritless you know there's nothing
shocking about the United States
rejecting a case of genocide against
Israel its Ally that it supported
financed and armed its war in Gaza
nothing surprising there what is
shocking is that uh Mr
Kirby would simply put it in three words
meritless counterproductive and
baseless I think South
Africa deserves better than that I think
the United States owes South Africa a
bit more respect a bit more diplomatic
courtesy than that to explain what is
wrong with that I personally as an
academic who read it twice the 70 plus
pages I take it person as a personal
insult to my intelligence that Mr Kirby
would just stand there on the podium of
the White House and say minutess
counterproductive baseless forget about
it wait a minute can you and can you
show me a single line in the 70 page
document that is not anchored based in
fact because I looked to see what are
the points of and the
weaknesses in this document I could not
see a single phrase there that was not
sourced and mostly on the basis of the
United Nations documents and
international human rights organizations
and Israeli sources there are there are
10 pages or 10 pages in that document
that basically site one Israeli official
after another one Israeli Minister after
another one Israeli General after
another one Israeli parliamentarian
after another
right that show intent to harm the
people in Gaza that while this is called
a
war against Hamas in every possible way
it's a war against Gaza so the idea that
there's a war they don't no one's
debating that and no one's debating even
the causes of this war the document does
not debate that does not debate whether
Israel should be or should not be at war
against Hamas it's about the conduct of
this war the dis proportionality the
collective punishment the war crimes and
so on so forth well let's talk a little
bit more about that because I'm just
hearing that the death toll in Gaza has
been updated now it stands at
22,43 it's just gone up by more than 100
and it's doing so every 24 hours the
death toll is extraordinary so even for
us nonacademic
it's very hard to understand the US's
position here absolutely and
um just judging from the bombings and
the collective punishment and the intent
behind it by Israeli officials the
civilians are clearly the target the
Civil the civil and the Civic
infrastructure is the target Hamas is
the collateral damage here that's my
interpretation that's I'm not talking
about the documents right so for Mr
Kirby
who only recently was asked right I
mean another laugh he was asked recently
is Israel committing war crimes in Gaza
he said what are you asking me for I'm
not an international
lawyer he's asked
yesterday is it committing genocide in
Gaza baseless
meritless counterproductive we thought
he's not an international lawyer so how
is he not making a judgment on war crime
but making the bigger judgment on
genocide South Africa deserves better
the United State spokesperson owes South
Africa a bit more respect and owes the
tens of
academics experts on genocide including
Jewish experts on genocide Israelis who
have been
saying that this is a case of genocide
against Israel right so clearly there's
a certain you know sense of
denial in Washington about this so
what's what's counterproductive and
baseless and meritless is the American
response to the South African case Okay
Maan thanks very much for the moment
joining us here on set